muchas gracias señor embajador es
increíble estar con angela y con emanuel
acabo de pasar buena parte de la mañana
a washington juntos quiero decirle hola
hola a todos y agradecerle a la
conferencia emery por alojar esta sesión
especial durante décadas como usted ha
resaltado participe en esta conferencia
como senador de eeuu junto a mis colegas
de ambos lados del pasillo para
reafirmar la importancia de la alianza
transpacífica tres veces como
vicepresidente de eeuu incluyendo la
entrega del primer discurso de política
internacional de administración obama
baile en los primeros meses del cargo y
hace dos años como usted resaltó cuando
hable la última vez en múnich los
ciudadanos era un docente no un oficial
elegido pero lo dije en ese momento
estaremos de vuelta y soy un hombre de
palabra
eeuu está de vuelta les hablo de como
presidente de eeuu en el inicio de mi
administración estoy enviando un mensaje
claro al mundo
eeuu está de vuelta
la alianza transatlántica está de vuelta
y no estamos mirando hacia atrás ya
estamos mirando hacia adelante juntos se
resume a esto
la alianza transatlántica es una base
fuerte la el cimiento en el que reposa
toda nuestra seguridad colectiva y
nuestra prosperidad compartida
la alianza entre europa y eeuu en mi
perspectiva es y debe permanecer el
cimiento de todo lo que esperamos lograr
en el siglo 21 así como hicimos en el
siglo 20 el desafío que enfrentamos hoy
los desafíos son diferentes estamos en
un punto de inflexión con lo hablé a
ustedes como senado incluso como
vicepresidente la dinámica global ya
había cambiado había nuevas crisis que
requerían nuestra atención no nos
podemos enfocar solamente en la
competencia entre países que amenazan
con dividir el mundo o en desafíos
globales que amenazan con hundir nos
juntos y no cooperamos debemos hacer
ambos trabajar con esos aliados con
nuestros amigos déjenme borrar cualquier
tipo de duda que esté pendiente los eeuu
trabajarán de manera cercana con
nuestros aliados de la unión europea
con las capitales del mundo desde roma a
riga para cumplir todos los desafíos que
enfrentamos seguimos respaldando la meta
de que europa esté unida libre a salvo
eeuu está completamente comprometida con
la alianza de la otan
le doy la bienvenida a las inversiones
militares que han hecho que nos han
permitido compartir esta defensa saben
para mí y para los eeuu para todos
tenemos la fe en el artículo 5 es una
garantía un ataque contra uno de
nosotros un ataque contra todos
esa es nuestra promesa irrebatible la
única vez que el artículo 5 ha sido
invocado fue después de que los estados
unidos fueran atacados en el 9/11
ustedes nuestros aliados si no era
nosotros para luchar contra el cambio y
los eeuu se comprometieron para
consultar de manera cercana con los
aliados de la otan a la hora de avanzar
en afganistán
mi administración respalda los procesos
diplomáticos en curso
para llevar a fin esta guerra que está
acercándose a los 20 años seguimos
comprometidos para asegurados que
afganistán nunca provea las bases de
ataques terroristas contra eeuu o
controle sus aliados nuestros aliados
europeos también están del lado nuestro
para combatir a isis sólo esta semana el
administrador de defensa de la otan
lanzó una misión de consejería y
entrenamiento iraquí esto será vital
para la lucha actual contra this is no
podemos permitirle a isis reabrir y
reagruparse y amenazar gente en el medio
oriente eeuu en cualquier parte del
mundo y aunque los eeuu está atravesando
por la tercera revisión de la
perspectiva de su ejército en todo el
mundo
y el retiro de tropas estoy levantando
un tope impuesto por la anterior
administración y una serie de en las
fuerzas armadas que están basadas en
alemania sé que los últimos países han
probado nuestra alianza transatlántica
pero los eeuu están determinados
determinados a reconectarse con europa a
consultar con ustedes a ganarse de nuevo
la confianza y el liderazgo temprano hoy
participé en el primer encuentro de los
bienes del g7 hablé de la necesidad para
coordinar acciones multilaterales para
enfrentar el commit 19 la crisis
económica global y la crisis acelerada
al clima tantas cosas más lograr estas
metas va a depender
en una proposición a propuesta
estratégica esto es que los eeuu deben
renovar las ventajas y los compromisos
estadounidenses para enfrentar los
desafíos de hoy desde una posición de
fortaleza eso significa reconstruir las
bases económicas mejor reclamar el lugar
en las instituciones internacionales
y defender los valores en casa
y realzar las voces para defenderlo
fuera de casa muerto dice modernizar las
capacidades militares mientras se lidera
el camino con la diplomacia revitalizar
la red de alianzas de eeuu que han hecho
que el mundo sea seguro para todos
y saben yo espero
que las otras democracias se unan con
nosotros en este trabajo vital nuestras
alianzas han soportado han crecido mucho
durante los años porque están basadas en
la riqueza de nuestros valores
democráticos compartidos no son
transaccionales
no hay nada extractivo ahí está
construido la visión de un mundo donde
cada voz importante donde los derechos
de todos son protegidos y el estado de
derecho sostenido nada de esto ninguno
de nosotros ha tenido un éxito completo
en esta división seguimos trabajando en
tantos lugares incluyendo europa y eeuu
el progreso democrático está bajo asalto
yo sé
los conozco a muchos de ustedes desde
hace mucho tiempo
saben que hablo como pienso déjeme ser
muy directo con ustedes estamos en medio
de un debate fundamental sobre el futuro
y la dirección de nuestro mundo estamos
en un punto de inflexión entre aquellos
que discuten que dicen que dados los
desafíos que enfrentamos desde la cuarta
industria la revolución industrial hasta
la pandemia global las autocracias ellos
dicen que la autocracia es el mejor
camino posible aquellos que tienen que
la democracia es esencial esencial para
enfrentar estos desafíos los
historiadores se examinarán escribirán
sobre este momento aquí y lo escribirán
como un punto de inflexión como acabo de
decir y yo creo que cada onza de mi ser
con causa de mi ser que la democracia
debe prevalecer debemos demostrar que la
democracia todavía puede responder para
nosotros para este pueblo en este mundo
cambiante eso es mi perspectiva en
nuestra misión la misión que nos va a
unir la democracia no ocurre por
accidente debemos defenderla luchar por
ella
fortalecerla renovar la debemos probar
que nuestro modelo no es una reliquia de
la historia
es la mejor manera de revitalizar la
promesa del futuro y si trabajamos
juntos con estos aliados democráticos
con fortaleza con confianza creo y sé
que superaremos cada desafío y acá
queremos pararnos juntos por esta
competencia que ha aparecido con china
como los eeuu europa y asia pueden
trabajar juntos para asegurar la paz y
defender los valores compartidos avanzar
en la prosperidad en todo el pacífico
debe ser uno de los esfuerzos más
consecuentes que debemos asumir la
competencia con china va a ser ruda eso
es lo que yo espero y eso es lo que
quiero porque yo creo en el sistema
global europa eeuu juntos con sus
aliados y el indo pacífica
el indo pacífico creo que hemos
trabajado muy duro para creo que este es
el sistema en los últimos 70 años
podemos manejar el futuro
pero para hacerlo debemos estar claros
sobre las inversiones históricas y las
alianzas que esto requiere debemos
proteger y proteger la propiedad
intelectual la creación de los genios
todo esto que pasa con esta sociedad
democrática crítica de ideas debemos
asegurarnos que los beneficios del
crecimiento sean compartidos ampliamente
y no sólo por unos pocos debemos
rechazar los abusos económicos y la
cohesión del gobierno china que
disminuyen y que acaban las bases de el
sistema económico mundial todos todos
deben jugar bajo las mismas reglas
eeuu las competencias europeas se les
requiere que muestren públicamente sus
estructuras de gobierno y que cumplen
con reglas para evitar prácticas de
monopolio y corruptas los chinos deben
cumplir los mismos estándares deben
darle forma a las
leyes que darán avance la inteligencia
artificial la biotecnología
para poder usarlos para sacar a la gente
de los malos lugares no para sostenerlos
en la pobreza
vamos a defender los valores
democráticos que hacen que sea posible
que nosotros logremos todo vamos a
rechazar a aquellos que quieren
monopolizar y normalizar la represión
miren esto también así también vamos a
resolver la amenaza de rusia estos
ataques crímenes en contra la democracia
la corrección usada como arma para
amenazar nuestro gobierno los raiders
rusos quieren que la gente piense que su
sistema es más corrupto o tan corrupto
como el de ellos pero el mundo sabe que
eso no es cierto incluyendo los propios
ciudadanos rusos
putin busca debilitar el proyecto
europeo y nuestra alianza de la otan
él quiere eliminar la unidad
transatlántica y nuestra resolución
porque es muy fácil para el clima para
clement hacer bullying a estados
individuales en vez de negociar con una
alianza fuerte con una comunidad de
unidad por eso es que
defiendo la soberanía la integridad
territorial de ucrania sigue siendo una
gran preocupación para el mundo para
eeuu por eso es que estamos
enfrentándonos al hackeo y a la
irresponsabilidad rusa en eeuu en el
mundo esto se ha convertido crítico para
proteger nuestra seguridad colectiva
nuevos desafíos con rusia pueden ser
desafío puede ser diferentes a los que
tenemos con china pero son igual de
reales y no es el este contra el oeste
no es que queramos un conflicto queremos
un futuro de todas las naciones puedan
determinar libremente su propio camino
sin una amenaza de violencia o coerción
no podemos y no debemos volver a esta
oposición rígida de la guerra fría la
competencia no debe acabar con la
cooperación en temas que nos afectan a
todos por ejemplo
debemos cooperar si queremos vencer el
cóver alcoy 19 en cualquier parte
mi primer memorando de seguridad
se enfocó en aumentar la respuesta
humanitaria y de salud para vender para
besar el kobe 19 y para prevenir mejor y
preparar mejor la nueva pac de la
próxima pandemia hoy estoy anunciando
que los estados unidos harán una
donación de 2 mil millones de dólares
para kóvacs con la promesa de unos 2 mil
millones adicionales hay otros que van a
hacer este anuncio de nuevo incluso
aunque luchamos para salir de los
dientes de estas pandemias la
resurgencia del ébola en áfrica es un
recordatorio bastante triste de que
debemos trabajar de manera simultánea
para financiar la seguridad sanitaria
fortalecer los sistemas de salud
nacionales y crear sistemas de alerta
temprana para prevenir y responder a
futuras amenazas biológicas porque puede
que siga volviendo debemos trabajar
juntos para fortalecer y reformar la o
ms necesitamos un sistema de naciones
unidas enfocada en amenazas biológicas
que pueda actuar rápidamente parecido
similarmente no podemos retrasar más
hacer el mínimo de nuevo para enfrentar
el cambio climático esta es una crisis
global existencial y todos sufrimos
todos sufriremos las consecuencias y
fracasamos debemos acelerar rápidamente
nuestros compromisos para disminuir
nuestras emisiones y que todos sean
responsables para enfrentar y lograr
nuestras metas y aumentar nuestras
ambiciones por eso es que como
presidente me uní inmediatamente de
nuevo al acuerdo de parís y por eso es
que eeuu hoy de nuevo spark es parte del
acuerdo de parís que hicimos juntos el
día de la tierra haré una cumbre de
líderes para ver si logramos acciones
más ambiciosas entre los emisores más
grandes incluyendo acción doméstica aquí
en eeuu
alegra estoy agradecido por el liderazgo
de eeuu en algo de europa en estos temas
de medio ambiente los últimos años
juntos podemos invertir en innovaciones
en lógicas que van a alimentar nuestros
futuros de energía eléctrica y construir
las soluciones energéticas para los
mercados globales la amenaza de la
proliferación nuclear también sigue
requiriendo una diplomacia en
cooperación cercana necesitamos
transparencia comunica comunicación para
minimizar el riesgo de malentendidos
estratégicos o de errores por eso es que
eeuu y rusia
ahora tiene otra competencia extendieron
este tratado por cuatro años más
una vez más me dice presidente por eso
es que estamos preparados para
reconectarnos y hacer negociaciones con
el p-51 en temas como el desarrollo
nuclear de irán y también debemos
dirigirnos a irán para sus actividades
que se establecen mediante vamos a
trabajar en alianza con nuestros aliados
europeos para proceder
también trabajaremos juntos
para acabar para asegurar de que los
grupos se realizan no accedan a material
nuclear en la perspectiva de desafíos
que europa y eeuu deben enfrentar juntos
es amplia y compleja y me emociona mucho
saber qué va a pasar en los discursos de
mis siguientes bueno amigos y líderes
angela merkel y sus ideas sobre el
camino aquí adelante juntos deben
concluir con eso no podemos permitir que
la duda nos impida conectarnos uno a
otro o con todo el mundo los últimos
cuatro años han sido difíciles pero
europa y eeuu deben liderar el camino
con confianza de nuevo con fe en sus
propias capacidades con compromiso a su
propia renovación con confianza el uno
en el otro y la capacidad de europa y de
eeuu de enfrentar cualquier desafío
y asegurar el futuro juntos y sabe y sé
que podemos hacer esto lo hemos hecho
antes apenas ayer después
después de un viaje de 7 meses y 300
millones de millas
la nasa aterrizó el explorador
percibirse en marte es una misión de
exploración con el evento elementos que
fueron traídos por nuestros aliados
europeos para buscar evidencia de la
posibilidad de que hubiera vida en otro
planeta y otros misterios del universo
donde los próximos años
bueno perseveren va a buscar muestras
del planeta rojo y las va a reunir para
que llegue otra misión y otro explorador
que ha sido considerado un esfuerzo
conjunto entre eeuu europa post
recuperen estas muestras y las traigan a
casa para que las observemos todos
nosotros eso es lo que podemos hacer
juntos
y esa capacidad sin límites de llevarnos
de ida y vuelta a marte no podemos
permitir que nadie los diga que no
podemos resolver ningún desafío no hay
ningún desafío que no podemos resolver
la tierra tenemos todo lo que
necesitamos y quiero que sepan que los
estados unidos hará su parte estará del
lado de ustedes luchará por los valores
que compartimos enfrentar e enfrentar
los desafíos de este nuevo momento de la
historia
eeuu está de vuelta
entonces reunamos nos demostremos a
nuestros bisnietos cuando sepan de
nosotros que la democracia la democracia
la democracia funciona y que juntos
no hay nada que no podamos hacer así que
vamos a trabajar muchas gracias a todos